please welcome Academy Award nominee
Diane Lane and John Cusack
the documentary filmmaker takes a look
at real life and in the case of the
documentary Short subject that look is
brief but no less important the nominees
in the category Best Documentary Short
subject are asylum Sandi McLeod and
Ginny ret occur
Chernobyl hearts marianne de Leo and
fairytales Katja a song Chernobyl heart
Marianne Julia
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for Mary Ann's of the
thank you this is amazing honor I feel
you're also honoring the people of
Chernobyl who are suffering the effects
of radiation still 18 years later after
the world's worst accident at the
reactor I could not have made this film
without ad Roche she's up there she
heads the Chernobyl children's project
and they are saving lives every day
80 is a true hero Sheila Nevins from HBO
has been a wonderful mentor and she's an
amazing woman
and I wouldn't be standing it without
her it's not easy to stand to hear dr.
William Novick also saves the lives of
children in Belarus and all over the
world with the International Children's
Heart Foundation
Angie Kenny is also here she's my friend
and worked on the film and I want to
thank her I want to thank John custodial
or Helio Velasco I want to thank my
mother who's here with me tonight for
she's smiling for everything my father
was home in Pearl River for being there
for me all my brothers and sisters have
a big family I won't name them all but
they're all here and I love them all and
I thank them their support thank you
very much
ladies and gentlemen Best Actress
nominee Naomi Watts and Best Supporting
Actor nominee Alec Baldwin
a good documentary can open your eyes to
what is already right in front of us
films like Harlan County USA and common
threads tonight's nominees are an
eclectic or of an eclectic subject
matter but no less thought-provoking or
provocative here are the nominees for
Best Documentary Feature
while sorrows Carlos Bosch and Joseph
Maria de Medici capturing the Friedman's
Andrew Jarecki and Mark smelling the fog
of war Errol Morris and Michael Williams
my architect Nathaniel Khan and Susan
are bare the Weather Underground Sam
green and Bill Siegel and the Oscar goes
to the fog of war arrow mark
this is the first Academy Award a
nomination for Errol Morris and Michael
Williams
this thing is heavy
I'd like to thank the Academy for
finally recognizing my films thank you
so very very very much I thought it
would never happen I'd like to thank my
very good friends at Sony Pictures
Classics Michael Barker Tom Barnard no
one would get to see this movie without
them my to producers michael williams
julie albergue couldn't have made the
movie without them either my
long-suffering editors Charlie Silver
Brad fuller and Karen schmear and Doug
Abel thank you all so very very much and
believe it or not Robert McNamara with
whom if he hadn't done it there would
have been no film 40 years ago this
country went down a rabbit hole in
Vietnam and millions died I fear we're
going down a rabbit hole once again
and if people can stop and think and
reflect on some of the ideas and issues
in this movie
perhaps I've done some damn good here
thank you very very much
I can't wait for his tax audit
scary times